[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the political editors of the daily
mirror and the sun pepper creera and
harry cole so good to see both good
evening to both of you
very happy to say you're both going to
be with us all the way through till
midnight
first though let's take a look at what's
making the front pages shall we this
evening and the guardian reports that
the chancellor rishi sunak will use his
budget speech on wednesday to announce
an end to the public sector pay freeze
and an increase in the national minimum
wage and that's also the top story for
the telegraph 2 which says 5 million
workers will be affected by that change
according to the daily mail 7 million
people stand to be better off
while the express puts the figure at 8
million
meanwhile the times warns motorists to
brace for a winter of rising costs amid
rising fuel prices
the eye hears from a former senior
adviser to the government on education
who believes that pupils should be given
more help to catch up on their studies
after the pandemic
criticism of recycling by the prime
minister a week before the cop 26
climate summit is the lead story for the
metro according to the financial times
concerns over security have been
prompted by the uk's three spy agencies
contracting with amazon to host
classified documents on its aws cloud
service
the start reports on fears of a shortage
of bus drivers
and the sun has heard that the next
series of the crown will recreate the
famous tv interview between princess
diana and martin beshear despite
apparent objections from prince william
so plenty to get our teeth into there
with pippa crea and uh harry cole uh
welcome welcome to both of you we are
kicking off um with uh a story that's
featuring as we saw there on a couple of
the front pages and the guardian first
of all pippa
their headline is soon act to scrap
public sector pay freeze and missed amid
cost of living crisis so yet another
announcement ahead of the budget and
not the first one of the day to to
tackle this cost of living crisis
yes um there's a couple of big
announcements on pay um today ahead of
ahead of the budget i mean i'm sure
we'll come to the fact that the
government has seemed to have announced
most of its budget in advance of the
actual statement which has obviously got
the speakers back up and is a rather
unusual way to approach things um but uh
we've heard a lot from the government in
recent weeks about
wages and their
desire to drive up wages and make
britain a high-wage economy because this
has always been very tricky because it's
set against a backdrop of years and
years of public sector pay freezes and
if you look at sort of real terms um pay
of the public sector teachers nhs and so
on compared to when the conservatives
came to power it's not a very pretty
picture and then the second aspect of it
is of course the minimum wage
now the the increase in the minimum wage
which has been announced or been
confirmed tonight um is as recommended
by the low pay commission and of course
it's great news that the government has
decided to um to just to back that
increase from 8.91 an hour to 9 pounds
fifty per per hour that will mean um a
great deal to lots of people uh
particularly low paid people however um
i think it's worth saying that the
government claims that this is going to
increase salary for some of the worst
paids the lowest paid by a thousand
pounds a year are very far from the mark
and you have got really expected
economists including people like paul
johnson from the ifs suggesting today
that is obviously not true that it's
going to bring them a thousand pounds
extra a year and of course is also
against backdrop of the the rising cost
of living crisis energy prices going up
the universal credit being cut by more
than a thousand pounds a year for many
of these same people um and next year's
national insurance tax increases so
overall while of course you'd welcome
and increase the minimum wage it's not
quite as clear-cut as saying that
everybody's going to get all that money
when cost of living pressures are so
huge harry what do you make of this i
mean the daily telegraph picks up the
same story doesn't it pay rise for 5
million public sector workers although
as we saw earlier different papers um
assess uh the figure differently um up
to eight million i think one of the
papers was saying but what do you make
of those points that pippa was making
there some people are saying this it
isn't actually going to make a huge
amount of difference clearly it's
welcome but they do point out these
higher inflation this this cut to the
universal credit that getting rid of the
uplift
but also the hike in national insurance
is it really going to be enough to make
people
feel better off
um i'm not sure about feeling better off
but on paper it is a remarkable rise i
think it's the second largest uh rise in
the minimum wage in a single budget
since um since the financial crash um
someone will immediately tweet me to
tell you i'm wrong on that but that's i
think it's the second of the third
highest rise in in in more than a decade
so
it is a big moment um boris johnson
spent his entire conference speech
talking about the fact that britain's
need a pay rise and he was in trying to
encourage the private sector and
businesses to hike wages naturally now
lots of them have sainsbury's for
example when morrison's this this winter
our height are paying um quite
significantly above the minimum wage for
their temporary christmas workers
because of a shortage of workers and hgv
uh companies are obviously hiking the
pay of um pay of lorry drivers
automatically but to make that demand of
of of the private sector everyone
basically said to the prime minister and
the chancellor you've got to pull that
lever yourself as well you've got one of
the biggest leaders you have which is
the pay that is the pay of the private
of the public sector now you can't go
around charging around asking everyone
to
you know give people to pay rise if
you're not prepared to do it yourself so
since conference we've been sort of
slightly expecting this movement um the
the chancellor made a big deal tonight
of the of the private sector pay for his
being a pause rather than a blanket
freeze now obviously nurses and nhs
workers were exempt last year which is
why there's a bit of confusion about
quite how many people are going to get a
pay rise next year this won't kick into
april 2022
um it's important to stress as well as
pippa says at that same time that
national insurance is going to be raided
uh in order to to pay for the nhs so the
money sort of washes around in itself um
but i think you know it it is a
significant moment i don't think i think
probably richie sidak would have quite
liked some of this to to stay
under his hat but the low paid
commission obviously came out today made
that recommendation that recommendation
was then circulated to circulated to the
business department the treasury to
number 10 and
once these things are starting to fly
around
lots of things out from under his hat
we've had so many announcements haven't
we as pippa says it's interesting to see
if there's something left left to
announce on wednesday um but
what about the fact that the prime
minister has made it very clear that he
wants to have this high wage high skill
economy i mean
where does this leave labour
given these announcements
are the tanks on its lawn to a certain
extent
well i think i mean labour has for some
time been called calling for um both
public sector pay to be increased and
the minimum wage to be increased they've
called for at least 10 pounds an hour
which is obviously slightly higher than
what we're getting
and public sector pay i think that they
would make the point that while of
course it is welcome it is also overdue
particularly when you look at the
the amount of effort that
not just nhs staff but teachers and you
know bin
collection
you know refuse collection drivers and
council workers and all sorts of other
people put in over the course of the
pandemic
and of course these are people that have
seen real term pay freezes for many
years this is not sort of like a
you know a consistent increase in their
salaries the government obviously
managed to to explain this away um last
time by suggesting that because
during the pandemic obviously private
sector pay
had stagnated that they couldn't justify
putting out public sector pay
that's obviously starting to change as
we're seeing increases in in
in wages for private sector workers but
you know your bigger point anna about um
about labor and parking tanks on lawn on
the lawn well i think it i think it's
absolutely the case that this is not
just not just with wages but on many
issues but one of the reasons that boris
johnson has been so successful
politically is because he has picked
issues which actually unite many people
and
perhaps the scene more traditionally as
as labor issues and they're trying to
sort of reframe the narrative you know
we've seen it with with him claiming
that the tories are the part of the nhs
well i think there's some way off the
public being convinced of that but it is
just one example leveling up is another
one
of areas which you would traditionally
see as being more popular with um you
know with labour voters and let's move
on the harry to the eye because there
are lots of demands obviously for cash
coming up with the spending review and
the budget and the eye focuses on
schools and um
a push to get more money are they likely
to get it is education got to get more
money
well the reason lots of this stuff has
seemed to have
sort of been pre-trailed i think is
because we don't just have the budget we
have the spending review as well which
doesn't which sets the departmental
budgets over the next three years so
this is sort of a budget plus if that
makes sense so a lot of the bigger
figures we're seeing flying around are
to do with the departmental spending for
the next three years and it does feel a
little bit like um speaking to people
tonight that whereas the leveling up um
sort of michael goves of this world and
um
and the nhs obviously have done well out
of the spending review there's
increasing concern that the education
department had have not now obviously
the uh the the government's own sort of
independent reviewer of education what
catch-up needs kevin collins stormed out
because he said that
the government will woefully under
funding um schools catch up obviously
there's been a change of secretary of
state as well at the department of
education um with gavin williamson's
departure and redeems the hardware's
arrival and he wondered how something
slipped through the net here and did the
has the education department missed out
have they not made the best case
possible for more money rishi sooner was
very clear on um on a rival broadcaster
um just just the other morning saying
actually
you know you know the case for extending
the school day hasn't been made the case
is actually you know it's actually a
much stronger argument to be to made for
one-on-one tuition uh sorry sorry small
group tuition rather than extending the
blanket extension to school days so it
feels to me like there's some unresolved
business there and um it might be that
one of the bigger losers of the uh of
the of the spending review is the
education department not a traditional
department to take that sort of thing
lying down or indeed quietly yeah
interesting one and very quickly we
ought to go to a great paper but just
briefly tell us if you can about this um
story in the sun in harry's paper of
hugh duty they say and this is amongst
the news today that petrol is at its
highest price on record
yeah uh fuel rises i have meant that
we've got uh petrol per litre an
all-time high of
142.9 p
per litre at the pumps now this of
course fuel has been frozen for pretty
much a decade now the government could
make a lot of money from putting fuel up
um you know 50 billion lost revenue for
the treasury potentially but politically
it'd be very unpalatable particularly as
the cost of fuel is so high and there's
a lot of tory mps in the form of red
wall areas sort of you know blue collar
um seats who are very concerned about
the impact on you know the white van man
um to use a stereotype um but uh the
cons the impact of the political fallout
is they should put up perpetual prices
perpetual duty at this time and harry's
obviously got the story that uh once
again they are deciding to go for the
politically expedient um uh decision and
um and uh freeze fuel duty harry i
didn't realize it's actually your byline
on the story and i've got pippa to tell
us about it people did it people did it
really well
my apologies because my eyesight isn't
good enough the writing is very small
anyway well done harry
and thank you for explaining it to us
pippa we will take a break there save my
blushes do stay with us coming up
criticism of the uk spy agencies for
allowing classified documents to be
hosted on amazon's online cloud service
we're going to talk about that next
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me tonight preparer and
harry cole taking us through the papers
and harry we're going to kick off this
section with the front page of the
financial times and their main story
focuses on amazon so what do they say
yeah it's a sort of astonishing tale
really here of this weird complex
relationship that
the governments around the world do have
with big tech now it seems that gchq our
listening station have decided to put
all their baskets into amazon for their
web hosting i'm not sure what web
hosting their sort of data their data
hosting now like any big organization
our our security services are holding
vast amounts of online data um and you
can only imagine that they're probably
holding much more than most ordinary
companies or firms or businesses or
organizations and it's emerging the fda
got great stories here tomorrow that
they have got put all their eggs in one
basket and are only using amazon to host
it now that does seem like a little bit
of a strategically um
closed-minded decision i think and
perhaps you know given given the
problems we've had
not least without the british
government's relationship with amazon
and their tax status whether it's not a
domestic firm that could be doing this
they're all out tonight saying no amazon
won't have any access to
what's held on their servers and they're
the only company that are big enough to
do it but i suspect it will be a talker
not least when the chancellor stands up
uh on wednesday and starts demanding
they pay more tax yeah no that that
another one to watch for wednesday as
well and and
talking big tech there's um facebook has
been making headlines all through the
day hasn't it the mitra metro picks up
on this uh facebook is making hate worse
says ex-employee this is
francis haugen isn't it
the whistleblower who's been giving
evidence in america now giving evidence
here
yes she appeared in front of a
parliamentary committee today and it was
really very striking um you know she was
talking about mark zuckerberg having the
fate of three billion facebook users
three billion i mean that's a massive
number isn't it it's mind-boggling um in
in his in his hands and they of course
include millions of children that use
instagram and her suggestion
that really struck me was that it's
cheaper for the company to amplify hate
and division
uh divisive content than to make try and
make the web as sort of a social media a
more sort of compassionate caring place
she suggested it would it would take
about it would sliver off about 0.5
of um of the company's growth which um
you know we took billions and billions
of pounds but it's not 0.5 and you'd
like to think that they might be paid to
do it but apparently not the more
concerned according to her about the
bottom line and shareholders rather than
users and she warned that events such as
the u.s capitol riots the genocides in
myanmar and ethiopia were just the her
words the opening chapters of worst
events that could follow where where
facebook more
facebook not better regulated in other
parts of the world and of course the
west as well